pour la Touraine à l'heure de l'Irlande
ce soir pour la Saint-Patrick mais
derrière la bière qui coulera avec
modération évidemment l'angoisse des
brasseries indépendantes en cause le
prix des bouteilles de verre en hausse
de 60 % en un an alors certains sont
passés vous voyez ce reportage de Sarah
gros
Blin brasse manuellement sa bière à la
riche depuis 2017 ces dernières années
ce passionné a vu le coup de la
bouteille en verre explosé à ses débuts
il paye un contenant envers 16 centimes
contre 24 aujourd'hui soit un tiers de
son prix de revente bien s'ajouter
l'augmentation du coût des matières
premières et surtout du transport qui a
doublé en un an mais pas question de
gonfler ses prix ma société reste
rentable mais
je refuse de trop augmenter pour pour
continuer à avant de m'aimer bien au
plus grand nombre à faire découvrir mon
travail et après on bah je fais des
économies à l'inverse les entreprises
productrices de bouteilles en verre se
seraient enrichies un bénéfice supérieur
à 40% selon le syndicat national des
brasseries indépendantes
Maxime de citrogeaux est aussi brasseur
il produit ses bières à Rochecorbon
depuis 2018 trop dépendant du vert il
envisage de s'en passer de toute façon
chacun va devoir prendre ses
responsabilités que ce soit les variers
que ce soit les brasseurs et on va
devoir faire sans eux bientôt la canette
prend un essor important donc ça déjà
c'est une première chose pour se passer
de la bouteille les il y a beaucoup de
brasseurs qui font de plus en plus de
fus voilà pour boire à la pression la
pression c'est moins cher pour le
professionnel c'est moins cher pour le
public et puis aussi le système de
consignes de bouteilles là qui est en
train de revenir sur le devant de la
scène pour l'heure la France recense
plus de 2500 brasseries artisanales et
indépendantes un chiffre qui pourrait
diminuer si la situation ne s'améliore
pas